fallout 4 is automaton DLC dropped in  March and the next add-on is due this  month and now we know when the wasteland  workshop will be available I'm Tony and  this game SWAT news update will give  your settlement that finishing touch  wasteland workshop arrives on ps4 xbox  one and pc on april 12 this add-on  brings a ton of new construction  elements for your settlements including  nixie tube lighting letter kits and  taxidermy you'll also be able to build  cages that can trap creatures from all  across the Commonwealth so if you want  to fight a death claw and go all  gladiator style now you totally can  wasteland workshop is included in  fallout 4 season pass but it's also  available a la carte for five bucks the  games next expansion far Harbor is  coming in May and it'll be the largest  landmass Bethesda has ever created for a  DLC pack keep an eye on gamespot for  more updates and prepare to catch some  kittens next week  you